alexandria ocasio-cortez has tested
positive for kovid she is recovering at
home and this comes
very shortly after she was seen partying
masculists in miami i don't really care
that she got coveted everybody seems to
have gotten it i don't really care that
she was partying in miami in fact i
think it's pretty cool that people go to
miami and party because they want to
they want to go somewhere where they can
be free what i don't appreciate is her
repeated attacks on these states like
florida where they allow people to live
their lives and take responsibility for
themselves she had complained about
texas getting rid of their mask mandates
she's championed the governorship and
the politicians in new york for their
policies like mask mandates and vaccine
mandates and then goes down to florida
flouts everything that she claims to
support and then there she is getting
sick with kovid so a lot of people are
pointing out the hypocrisy and we'll get
into that and we've also got uh
cnn
now coming out and saying and this is
surprising because it comes from a cdc
director that
covet hospitalizations may be inflated
by 40 percent because they're listing
people hospitalized with kovid as
opposed to from kovid for which there is
a very big difference we'll talk about
all that plus we've got a story about a
suspected antifa arrested in florida
with a pipe bomb crazy story and joining
us to talk about this and more is mike
rowe that's true
i'm here thank you hey thanks for coming
man i can't decide if i'm in a studio or
a board room or like backstage at qvc
where all the tchotchkes imagine thank
you very much yeah might be for sale
it's impressive well are you referring
to ian's rock collection oh is that what
it is we got a wide shot here oh yeah
let me see if that's ian has a rock
collection on the table you can't
normally see your viewers would
definitely want to drink that in that is
uh that's obsidian we've got some of
course which is pyrite
iron pyrite yeah luke's got machetes
he's gold luke's got his his you never
know
you never know especially you know with
as crazy as things have been getting man
right how would you how would you
describe yourself
i mean i think most people know who you
are to be honest right you know
obviously homo sapien six
six foot mostly upright yeah yeah look i
forced the voice from that tv show
people watch sometimes you know that's
that's really where it started if
there's a wildebeest trying to get
through the vast reaches of the barren
serengeti but leaving the herd and
getting slowly eaten by the crocodile or
the hyena
it's probably me there you go telling
you about and it never works out for the
uh for the wildebeest by the way and you
also do uh you've dirty jobs you got a
podcast you have a foundation yeah dirty
jobs has been on the air 20 years wow 20
years straight we just started a new
season uh last week actually i was 15.
good for you
that's terrific that's terrific um
thanks tim yeah the uh i mean it's it's
really been the the the greatest
luckiest
privilege that i could do you know it's
a it's a tv show on the one hand but it
launched a foundation that i've been
running now for 14 years
and it's given me a weird
seat at the grown-up table when it comes
to talking about things like
the definition of a good job or the
value of a college education versus an
apprenticeship so i never planned for
any of it but because of that show and
other shows like it i uh i get to run a
foundation and mouth off to congress
from time to time and it's a kick sounds
great that's a blast we'll talk about it
we'll get in all of it we've got luke
hanging out well mike thanks so much for
coming on we definitely don't like
congress so anytime you can mouth off
against them we definitely approve of
that and uh before we begin we wanted to
remind everyone that when the corporate
media in unison tells you that there's
no mass formation psychosis that means
that there's no mass formation psychosis
and that's why i made this fictional
shirt which says
mass formation psychosis that maybe you
could get on the best polar growth
shirts.com and i just purely from the
bottom of my heart wanted to thank all
the fact checkers out there i almost
thought the government was being
tyrannical there for a second thank you
so much for clearing everything up for
me uh this should be a great episode
thanks for coming up hey ian crossland
what's up uh you can follow me in
crossland.net michael you ever go by
michael i just got my brother's name's
mike it's mr michael mr mike i think
i've heard it yeah
i hope that one day you'll do the voice
of planet earth the series i did oh is
that what you were talking about when
you said sigourney weaver was hired
originally and uh when they did the uh
the reboot i did it beautiful cool thank
you matt here's to many more seasons of
that thanks one of my favorite planets
actually it's beautiful it's a good one
yeah it's a good one
i am also here i'm delighted to have
mike oh hey look it's the top of my head
oh it's like i can't find it i got this
awesome okay i'm showing everyone this
awesome picture are you related are you
related to her it's just like my grandma
doesn't she she's so cute i love her
anyway why did you just switch to a
camera shot of diane because she's more
important than me no it's because i had
it on the room shot and it doesn't put
it right backwards so let's go anyway
i'm here i'm not dianne feinstein
tonight i'm very excited to have mike
rowe tonight i'm delighted to talk about
all this stuff i did not finish my
college education and i think that's
great so i hope hopefully we get into
some of that stuff i'm very excited to
rag on college yeah we'll get into that
before we get started my friends we have
an awesome sponsor today we have virtual
shield virtual private network go to
surfinginternetsafe.com and you can
secure your internet and get 50
off for life they say privacy isn't a
privilege it's a universal human right i
agree with that and now for those of you
aren't familiar with the virtual private
network service it's a basic layer of
security for you as you browse the
internet and actually uh considering
what we've been going through in recent
times seriously recommend this as well
as any other kind of encryption service
you can get a virtual private network
service make sure that your data from
point to point is going through an
encrypted service or at the very least
it's being masked so that governments
hackers corporations aren't going to be
able to steal your data it provides you
that level of protection let me give you
a real real world example we had a
journalist john solomon have his private
pho uh we'll just say his phone records
released by a member of congress a
certain member of congress and now the
january 6 committee instead of getting a
warrant and going to these individuals
like in the trump administration and
saying we would like to you know
subpoena your records they're going
straight to the phone companies who are
saying no problem and handing it all
right over now you can't prevent
everything but with a virtual private
network service you do get some basic
layer of security and let me explain one
more thing to you as it pertains to some
important legal cases
when you leave your home let's say in
the real world
people can take a picture of your face
and say well you're out in public but if
you have an expectation of privacy now
there's questions about whether or not
they can be filming you or floating refu
in public there's there's certain
questions about this what the government
has tried arguing is that if you're not
masking your internet traffic you have
no expectation of privacy using a basic
service isn't just to actually protect
your data but there's a good possibility
it could provide a legal defense if
you're saying i expect privacy while i
browse the web so again go to surfing
internetsafe.com you can get 50 off for
life from virtual shield where big fans
they've supported my work since the very
beginning on youtube so support
companies that support us and don't
forget go to timcast.com
become a member and you'll get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast we're going to have
a bonus segment coming up we do that
around 11 p.m monday through thursday
you're not gonna want to miss that and
don't forget to like this video right
now subscribe to this channel share the
show with your friends and let's get
into that first story
from the miami new times
coincidence alexandria ocasio-cortez
caught covid after partying in miami i
mean that's the gist of the story we saw
uh the news over the past couple of
weeks that aoc was seen hugging people
getting kissed by people partying at a
drag club and this is coming from a
person who has routinely ragged actually
you know what let me just pull the tweet
we got this tweet from aoc herself where
she said 93.2 percent of texans aren't
fully vaccinated mind you this is march
2nd the state just endured one disaster
worsened by selfishness and denial of
basic science and now conditions are
being set for another repealing the mask
mandate now endangers so many people
especially essential workers and the
vulnerable so perhaps her concern of the
mass mandate was only because of limited
vaccinations
and now she's changed her opinion sure
that's fine but she's also criticized
ron desantis of florida which i would
just say is wrong because she's choosing
to go party in his state while
criticizing him for the policies that
allows her to go party in a state and
now she has coveted so poetic justice or
or what hypocrisy well when you when you
try to silence speech when you weaponize
compliance and you disregard your own
decrees that you complain about other
people not following you're not on the
side of good it's also important to note
here that with this particular tweet on
march of 21 that she of course is
asserting that people will get hurt that
there will be some devastating
consequences because of texas moving
away from mandates moving away from top
down centralization of power of force
against the people who are living there
and the numbers don't lie when you look
at what happened in texas after this and
you compared to what happened in new
york there's a story there that of
course is being hidden away from the
general public that's how i see it and
uh you know i don't wish anyone would be
sick i don't think we should be
celebrating anyone be sick uh but you
know there this is the story that's
happening right now that is deserved to
at least be mentioned in my opinion i
think if i if i zoom out for my ego i
want her to be healthy i want it to be
easy like a low symptom or no symptom
illness and be done with it and realize
okay it's not that as bad as i thought
it was going to be kind of thing that's
what i want for the general system
i don't want to play hate and love with
this girl whatever but
it's the policy man
it's it's
if you're if you're in new york if
you're a congress person if you're a
governor and you're defending or
refusing to speak up in the face of
vaccine management mass mandates and
then you decide for my vacation i'm
going to go to the one i'm going i'm
going to go to one of the places where
they don't have these policies so i can
go party
i mean that is
that is everything wrong with politics
in my opinion i see i see conservatives
or republicans being like i don't like
masked mandates i won't wear one and
then they don't i'm like well that's
what they said i get it aoc who's like
you know the governor here can give
ronda santa some pointers and mass
mandates are important and then
but i'm gonna go party where the
governor does the opposite that it's the
hypocrisy i can't stand the single most
valuable thing right now is the thing
that's most singularly missing and
that's consistency
we're desperate for people i don't even
think it matters so much what they say
if it lines up with what they do
in a fairly consistent way that person
right now is going to be both respected
and probably in demand regardless of
what side of the aisle you sit on you
know i live in northern california and i
wrote
pretty pointedly
when the whole french laundry thing
happened with gavin newsom you know i
just said look this is not a small thing
you remember he was oh yeah he's out
there and he's without a mask shortly
after telling everybody they had to wear
a mask and didn't help that it was a
super fancy schmancy restaurant and he
was with all his buddies it was just a
bad look but
i just remember saying listen when it
comes to politics speaking only for
myself
i'll forgive stupidity i'll forgive
people being wrong and i'll forgive
people changing their minds
but it's really hard to forgive a
hypocrite yeah mike there was medical
professionals from the government of
california coming forward and saying
along with bureaucrats every time you
have a bite you need to put on your mask
afterwards as they were telling people
not to gather in large groups they were
shutting down restaurants all over
california
as he's going to have a dinner at one of
the fanciest restaurants in the world
sure with a huge crowd and then
thankfully because of citizen journalism
because of people caring about the story
this story was able to get out there to
the general public and show the
hypocrisy show just how hypocritical a
lot of these people are that will ruin
your life while living their best life
which is crazy i wonder if it's you know
for for people who
align themselves with like the
democratic establishment or or
democratic uh activists they overlook
the new some stuff or the or the whitmer
the pelosi or the maxine waters or you
know the list goes on i wonder if they
overlook that because their attitude is
the messaging is more important it
doesn't matter if a handful of people
are flouting the rules and ignoring it
so long as they're telling everyone to
follow the rules to keep us safe and
then i wonder if you know for
post-liberal libertarian conservative
whatever their attitude is are you being
honest are you an honest politician
which is rare to be honest it depends
how scared you are right if the if the
populace is freaked out to an eight or a
nine
they'll
absorb a level of hypocrisy that they
won't when they're at a five or a six or
a four or a five now we're becoming i've
just noticed it in the last couple of
weeks we're becoming less scared i just
had it got through it my folks both have
it they've come through it
it's not now just a question of how many
people do you know who have had it it's
we're starting to see and you can chalk
it up to omicron or therapeutics or
the
therapeutic nature of the vaccines
whatever it is people seem to be having
a much easier ride than we were yeah and
so as the fear level comes down
what happens now when you recall nancy
pelosi walking into
a salon to get her hair done when she
had specifically told people
that you're not allowed to do that you
feel differently now because you're not
as afraid as you were so there's a long
tail i think on hypocrisy and it's still
spooling out as we speak i bet this is
going to be like people that are
starting to it's dawning on them now
like now they're calming down they're
gonna see this and it's gonna be like
reliving trauma for these people so when
we or when anyone is gonna approach them
about like hey just so you know i'm not
don't rub their nose in it when people
start coming around
treat it like past trauma be kind and
understanding people went through a lot
the last couple years yeah i know a lot
of people want to say i told you so well
that's not always the best kind of
approach especially when it comes to
someone coming out of a trauma-based
fear state that was instituted by a lot
of very powerful forces the corporate
media the politicians all took this
situation and let's be honest here from
my perspective exploited it to the
fullest extension
extent that they could in a way that
that ratcheted up the numbers of cases
ratcheted up the number of debts that
are now even in question by the
government's own answers and
explanations to what actually was going
on here cnn was talking about
gangbusters for ratings as they were
obsessing about the death counter on
their corporate media broadcast that of
course was celebrating that they were
able to ratchet up those numbers and get
more viewership because of that and that
is a sick mentality that deserves to be
checked and though they they they need
to be held responsible for it you know
that meme keep calm and acts or carry on
keep calm and carry on yeah
so uh
i i feel like this the corporate press
and many politicians like aoc were the
ones doing the opposite they were
telling you not to keep calm they were
saying the end is not panic panic yeah
they still are there was just an article
i read
maybe two weeks ago written by a doctor
over at johns hopkins i forget her name
it's not important though you can look
it up it's very specific though she's
laying out
the hellscape of january and february
and i've never read anything this dire
all right all the hospitals will be full
all of the pharmacies will be closed all
of the shelves will be empty please
listen to me please listen to this a
doctor at hopkins right now we're
january 10th today in real time and
people are looking around
and so what do we do you know you're
talking about being graceful and i think
that's great and you're talking about we
should understand and i i think that's
great too but look there are
consequences of living at def con 5.
where's the def con one what's the bad
one one's the better one you can't live
at one
right maybe for 15 days maybe for a
while but but it starts to wear down you
know and it's i mean you don't have to
look too far back in the history to see
what happens when people get bored with
being terrified
it happens and it's got nothing to do
with numbers or statistics it's got
nothing to do with facts or data it has
to do with with who with the way we're
wired remember in the battle of britain
right during the blitz those those
people were bombed every day and they
went underground and they lived
underground for
for a week and then they started to
stick their heads out bombs still
falling yep you know two weeks later
they're opening shops three weeks later
they're back in school bombs are still
falling the bombs never stopped falling
but after a month and a half it was just
look this is bad this is very very very
very bad but we're not going to spend
the rest of our lives in that state
there's videos out of syria during the
civil war in places like aleppo where
the buildings are completely wiped out
there's there's no sign of civilization
but people except for the people that
are carrying food and working and you're
wondering you can hear gunshots go off
in the distance but these people say
it's either i just wither and die in a
hole or i get out to get food and living
even amidst this conflict i think they
needed the panic and they wouldn't be
able to exploit this entire situation if
there wasn't a panic and it's important
to understand they they created it in
many important circumstances with that
fear comes anxiety comes depression
comes a lot of psychological disorders
if we look at the mental health of
america it has steadily declined over
the years and dramatically when when
covet came to the world because
politicians were exploiting that and
this kind of sick deprived behavior i
think is perfectly represented by this
latest la times column that literally is
titled mocking anti-vaxxers deaths is
ghoulish yes but necessary right that is
crazy imagine working on a newspaper
saying this out loud and still
exploiting it when again the data should
be questioned here and the facts still
aren't figured out here so the arguments
she's making here for it being necessary
it's it's such a complex web of of just
emotions that they throw at you so you
don't look at this calmly rationally
because if you did you wouldn't be going
along with any of this nonsense think
about the fact that that that article
got past an editor probably several
editors and so this the thing that
scares me is that there's somebody in
the newsroom who says you know they
enjoy mocking or they should people
should be mocking those who die and then
everyone around them being like yeah we
we agree with this and so much that we
want to publish this
that says to me that we're really
separated in this country from
celebrating death it's even even being
neutral about it because they may not
agree but they may they're obviously not
disagreeing because they put it forward
and being neutral towards evil is just
as bad as being evil well there you go
right good germans
yeah that's it yeah order followers it
wasn't the nazi party it was
all the ones who sat by but look beside
that it's just uh
i forgot what i was going to say dawg
gone it was going to be good too
it was going to be a good one it was
going to be a good one it was going to
oh
as a journalist right i mean somewhere
along the line with an article like the
one you just quoted and with the thing i
was just talking about before
shouldn't somebody be asking the
question
what is persuasive
is it persuasive for instance
to point to the people who for whatever
reason haven't been vaccinated
and identify them
as the proximate cause of all of the
problems now it you can have the
conversation about whether they are or
whether they're not but from an advocacy
standpoint from a journalistic
standpoint you know
do those people
find it persuasive to be put into a a
box of deplorables we we've had a couple
people on the show we've disagreed with
and typically i'll ask them you know why
don't you you know flies with honey why
don't you try and advocate and be nice
and empathize
it doesn't seem like people want to do
it right so this article saying we
should mock those who die from covet
obviously it's not persuasive obviously
it's antagonistic but they're doing it
not because they actually want to be
persuasive at least in my view they're
doing it because i think it is a tribal
rallying cry that will generate traffic
among their side make them feel good you
know you're right we you know you've got
someone who's a really nasty person on
facebook they see the article and they
go that's right i should be a jerk on
facebook but it doesn't feel good but
this is another aspect of it these are
talking points that are issued not just
by l.a times
reporters quote end quote but these are
also similar comments expressed by world
leaders like justin trudeau that when
talking about the unvaccinated said do
we tolerate these people we have uh
rachael the former banker emmanuel
macron who literally came on the world
stage and said these people are not
these people shouldn't be considered
citizens for for what they're doing
because they're irresponsible for their
health
these are arguments and talking points
that have ratcheted up at this level
that are extremely insane extremely
draconian from very powerful
institutions very powerful people that
in in my understanding are very
dangerous especially when you look at
them with these specific comments with a
context in history let me jump to this
story right here from newsbusters cnn
tapper finally discover misleading covet
hospitalization numbers my response to
this is conspiracy theorists 49 837
corporate press zero
this is this is something that you know
independent media has talked about for
some time it's something that the quote
unquote conspiracy theorists have been
saying for some time that there is a
difference between being hospitalized
with covid meaning you went there for
some reason it turns out you had coveted
and being hospitalized from covid
newsbuster's uh reports for nearly two
years and with the midterm election
coming up conservatives and republicans
were vilified as conspiracy theorists
for raising questions about covet
hospitalization numbers when it came to
who was there because of covid and who
just happened to be infected on monday
cnn and anchor uh cnn and anchor jake
tapper finally arrived at the scene to
ask the obvious questions after cdc
director dr richelle willenski admitted
to fox news the number is inflated by
upwards of 40 percent
tapper prefaced his late revelation by
prefacing to cnn's dr sanjay gupta that
quote the case numbers aren't really a
significant as significant as
hospitalizations because what's
important is how sick people are getting
and since cnn had obfuscated the idea
that the cdc was misleading people
tapper had to spell out what was going
on over the weekend the cdc director dr
rochelle walensky was asked how many
people are in the hospital for covid
versus how many people are in the
hospital with covid meaning they're for
uh that they're there for some reason
and it's also true they have coveted
after playing the sound bite of
willenski admitting up to 40 percent of
the patients who are coming in with
covet are coming in not because they're
sick with covet but because they're sick
with something else tapper seemed a bit
surprised and called it misleading
saying so the hospitals are still
stretched thin because of this so i'm
not trying to take away from that but if
40 in some hospitals 40 of the people
who have coveted don't necessarily have
problematic covet they're there because
they got in a car accident they're there
because you know they bumped their head
and they're being included as as in the
hospital with coven that number seems
kind of misleading
and there you go i mean it's something
we've long talked about and now finally
it's hitting the mainstream and i i i
why is it why why do you guys think that
is that they're flying because
not hurting people that bad relative to
the old version no that's not good
that's not what i mean what i mean is i
think this data has been out there
already i think tapper got omicron i
don't know if he did and he was like
what this was so you this was like
nothing why why are people wigging out
and so now he's like and there's the
with and from thing and and so it's all
like clicking for him now well that's my
person well there's a lot of things that
play here and i remember early on when
everything was happening there was a
case of of a man being shot in the head
that was listed as an official covet
death i believe in california and i'm
like how how does that make sense this
goes along i believe to what we were
saying before if you inflate the numbers
if you make them higher you're going to
scare a lot more people if you make them
believe that you might be a huge victim
here you might be hurt the chances of
being hurt or high high high and as soon
as i heard this story i'm like yes of
course we've been talking about this for
months because hospitals also are being
paid for every covet patient that they
have are also being paid for putting
patients on ventilators and are also
being paid for covered patients dying so
the you know
i don't i don't think there's you know
in some instances of financial incentive
but but there is a lot of money changing
hands here when the numbers go a
specific way here that do allude that
there is a possibility that this is true
we got the story from usa today our
ruling true we rate the claim that
hospitals get paid more if patients are
listed as covid19 and on ventilators as
true hospitals and doctors do get paid
more for medicare patients diagnosed
with covet 19 or if it's considered
presumed they have covid19 absent a
laboratory confirmed test and three
times more if the patients are placed on
a ventilator to cover the cost of care
and loss of business resulting from a
shift in focus to treat covet 19 cases
this is what people were saying all
throughout the last year if you get if
you go to the hospital this is this is
from april 27th 2020. it's almost two
years ago usa today told us this and
cnn's only now bringing it up
um in the long history of uh bromides
platitudes and tropes most have been
ultimately debunked over time they
become conventional wisdom and they
collapse under the weight of their own
nonsense
never has follow the money
been debunked
never ever once has it not proven to
lead you to the place where the truth is
you it might not be totally dispositive
but you can't
you can't minimize the importance of
people acting in their own financial
best interest i don't care who they are
i don't care if they're elected i don't
care if they're scientists it just
doesn't happen that's an extraordinary
thing to think about
the hundreds of thousands the millions
of dollars that are in the wind based on
a decision that ultimately is going to
be reported as fact that's a heck of a
thing yep cubono is always the question
that a lot of people who are profits who
benefits who
gets something from this and for the
government to incentivize and take our
money because people think it's free
money people think that a lot of these
procedures a lot of these products are
free they're not we're paying for them
in one way or another but but for the
government to incentivize and pay
hospitals to to to to give them more
money when they have more coveted cases
more ventilators more debts is again
incentivizing something that is
obviously something that clearly
shouldn't be incentivized and and for
that to happen it's absolutely crazy
we've been saying it for years and now
we finally know about it is this the
breaking point you know are we are you
mentioned i think you mentioned a moment
ago people are starting to get less
scared of this
well i for me
there's always uh
i call it a pos or a period of splat
all things have to go splat right before
you punch through and and there's it's
not written in the stars i don't i don't
know when it is exactly
but this will tip
right and it'll be a combination of
things and for me i i can feel it i i
feel
that a lot of things that a lot of
people i hold in high regard have been
saying for 18 months
are getting a kind of snowball feel
behind it and
and so yeah i think
i don't know that it'll get worse before
it gets better it might get a little
weirder over the next couple of weeks
but
look if if i were to guess i'd say we're
much much much closer to the end well
this goes along with the theory that i
was actually talking about a few weeks
ago that goes along with a lot of what
medical professionals are saying is that
because this omnicron is so transmissive
and less lethal that it will run through
people run through countries and then
people will go out the other end with
natural immunity and therefore
absolutely get rid of this uh pandemic
so this is a train of thinking that's
that's out there right now and i think a
lot of people in power might be
realizing that and that's why we're
having these shock announcements by the
cdc by cnn going back on essentially a
lot of the falsehoods surrounding this
entire story because the game could be
over in just a few weeks from now and
that means a lot of ramifications for a
lot of the people that betrayed us it
needs to be over especially politically
absolutely it's going to be a disaster
for those who are advocating for coveted
policies come november well this is what
i said after coming from new york city's
is talking to people there they had
enough they're they're sick of complying
with the whims of this insanity they're
sick of just just going along being told
to obey to to get permission to go to
the store to go to the theaters it's
absolutely insane and for for democrats
to win politically they have to get rid
of this idea that they have to be the
nanny state of the individual
controlling every aspect of their
existence and that's why with the
upcoming elections that was another
reason i brought up i think it was in
the sponsor lounge that me and you were
talking about this my kind of overall
theory why this is going to be ending
very soon because this is extremely
unpopular this goes against the free
spirit the free human will and there's
no way they could get away with this
moving forward from my perspective from
what i see and there's also this feeling
as mike explained that that it's there
and and look i think there's something
even bigger under all of it we can talk
about the politics and we can talk about
the science but you remember hans
christian anderson wrote an amazing
story
called the emperor's new clothes oh yeah
okay
now
if if you don't know the story the
bottom line is the emperor was convinced
that his new clothes were beautiful and
the tailors didn't really make any
clothes at all he was naked and he sat
naked on his throne as he was paraded
down the street and all of the
townspeople came out and they all ood
and odd at how beautiful his clothes
were and so it was just this giant weird
happy fiction unfolding in this little
town until a kid
a kid
pointed at the emperor and said
he's naked
and and then right it was a hush comes
over the crowd and then somebody else
said well you know he does appear to be
conspicuously nude right and and so if
you look back at the last 18 months guys
and and ask yourself okay
who's the kid
who's the kid in the crowd we can all
probably think you know joe roger
we were all thinking it said we are we
josek in the crowd um ben shapiro is a
kid in the crowd
you right i mean in a very very small
way i was saying some things very very
early on that got a lot of pushback with
regard to wait a second i'm not i'm not
trying to be disrespectful and i'm and
i'm not a luddite but i have some
questions especially when gavin is
dining out nancy's getting her hair done
and i have some questions right so i
think in a lot of ways to your point the
the temptation to say i told you so is
something that we ought to resist but
it's also something we ought to
acknowledge
because
if you've spent the last 18 months being
that kid in the crowd and now you're
finally starting to feel like oh wait a
minute okay so i'm not the only one that
sees
40 of the people in the hospital are not
there because of but with
that that that's
language matters even little
prepositions right that's a big big big
deal yeah if you listen to them talk
tapper at one point says that they're
they're with asymptomatic a bunch of
these 40 they just detected it
and well maybe it's because they're
getting money i like the uh you know
what you were saying about the kid in
the crowd that's the story but i also
wonder if there's another trope there in
that you know the king is demanding of
the subjects do as i say or else and
then the jester mocks him and everyone
laughs and he says don't laugh at me and
then jester mocks him again and that
deep power is the despot that's right so
that's that's that's you know possible
that's kind of how i see you know joe
rogan he's a comedian and when he does
his show and he does comedy when it is
entertainment be it serious or otherwise
people like being a part of it it feels
good so it's not necessarily the same
thing as the kids saying you know you
have no clothes and everyone kind of
being like well he said it i guess he's
right but also people feeling like now
it's now it's okay because everyone's
laughing together the point is it had to
be the kid because the adults couldn't
do it now in this corollary
look it could have been jake tapper 18
months ago but it wasn't it could have
been anderson cooper it could have go go
down the list and look at all of the
journalists
who could have been
that kid who could have been rogan
what what did it take
to really start the splat series of
dominoes to go it took a comedian who
got famous for eating maggots on a
reality show i don't think he encouraged
people
no no no he would eat one to shame them
in the donut oh yeah no joe would eat a
maggot are you kidding and and a
kickboxer and a martial artist yeah that
that's what we needed to get robert
malone out there to get the whole getter
thing happening yes
people never know how it's going to
start and we never know how it's going
to splat but it's almost always the
result of an unlikely voice but it's
it's it's it's amazing how
i'm just
flabbergasted at the thought that joe
rogan is our generations like walter
cronkite steve bannon explained it to us
if you remember what he was telling us
when he was here as a guest that during
the during the you know major uh
historical events like the civil war or
the revolutionary war it's never the
politicians of the people in prominence
that are the significant historical
figures it's always the the laborers the
farmers the the people who are affected
by these changes and decide to stand up
and and represent bigger ideas
themselves because of how affected they
are by them i want to i absolutely want
to talk about labor and everything i
want to talk about this story real quick
because it segues into a discussion
about jobs and labor we have this from
the post-millennial nearly 80 percent of
americans believe u.s is in a state of
decay the poll found that 76.8 of
respondents believe american society and
culture is in a state of decay a poll
from the trafalgar group and convention
of states action published on thursday
revealed basically what i just said
just 9.8 of respondents of the country
is in a state of progress so i bring
this up in in relation to what we're
talking about just because i wonder if
if our journalists can't do the job of
criticizing the establishment the
government the narratives being
objective or just countering the
authority then it seems to me like what
we're actually seeing is is tribalism
joe rogan is smeared and slammed as far
right by many of these outlets when he
challenges the establishment in this way
and these quote quote-unquote news
organizations just shill whatever the
government or establishment line is
that says to me it's not necessarily a
representative of decay in this country
although it seems like a lot of people
seem to believe this country isn't decay
but that we've we've fractured to a
point where both sides are probably
looking at each other as the problem as
the decay in this country you know what
i mean but it's not just it's not both
sides look how many sides are really
involved in the rot
our journalists let us down in ways that
we can't even imagine
um our politicians of course are in it
for the next election and they've let us
down in
i think a pretty equal way our
scientists
have let us down not because they're
scientists but because there's no
consensus and they all sound so damn
certain i don't mind you again i don't
mind you being wrong
but where's the humility where did the
humility go those are three big pillars
right there that i think disappointed a
lot of people but here's a fourth and
another reason why rogan matters
comedians
our comedians have let us down the court
jester that you referenced in anderson's
tale where is he right now chappelle's
doing yeoman's work in my view but i
look around i see a lot of comedians who
well to be fair there wasn't much they
could do for a year virtually it's a
different world you know they they were
hunkered down too but the carefulness
the carefulness with which comedy has
unfolded or failed to unfold and we can
blame cancer culture we can blame speech
you know that's there's plenty to talk
about why
but they let us down too nobody was
holding anybody's feet to the fire in a
really meaningful way
some people and that's why i you know i
like the story of the the emperor's
clothes right and and it does feel to me
like it represents a decay
it was scientists in establishment
institutions it was journalists for the
corporate press it was mainstream
politicians who are worried about their
donors they're all the ones who let us
down don't forget social media oligarchs
this was their time to shine
shout out to spotify for keeping this
knowledge on the radio
yeah absolutely i mean
the censorship that we deal with on on
youtube the censorship on twitter the
suppressing of of big political stories
it is all of these people standing there
watching the emperor which i guess just
is the narrative nobody wanted to be the
person who would call out and say hey
guys this doesn't make sense does it
as soon as anybody did the entire crowd
turned and yelled your right wing evil
evil
and so now
over the past couple of years we not
only had joe rogan we had ricky gervais
said was it was the oscars or whatever
when he just roasted all of them we've
had globes golden globes that's what it
was we had right we've had ryan long i
mean ryan long has been putting out
videos that have been gaining in
popularity because he's not a right-wing
guy he's just a comedian who's poking
fun
but you look we've got dr robert malone
we've got uh brett weinstein you you you
do have scientists researchers and
academics who have been speaking up but
when we look to our institutions
that's what's failed us now joe rogan is
interesting because he kind of occupies
both spaces he's got his netflix
specials he's got his mainstream arena
tour arena tours he's on spotify he's on
itunes but he's always been an
independent voice standing up for
himself and what he believes in
and that's kind of a bridge in my
opinion why he's been so important
is that regular people who don't care
for politics don't care for a narrative
listen they listen to his show and then
when he speaks out and does challenge a
system and does say fu to to all the
lies he does point at the emperor and
say you're not wearing any clothes and i
don't care
i can make a long list of things that
joe rogan said that i don't agree with
but i but i have a really hard time
finding an opinion that strikes me as
hypocritical
he's back to what we said very very
early on when when
when you get starved for authenticity
the first thing i start to look for
is
anybody
anybody whose words match up with what
they say and who if they if they
do overreach if they do get in their own
way they'll be the first to admit it so
he has
a measure of the humility that's lacking
in science in my view he certainly has a
comedian's sense of the absurd which he
uses but most importantly at least from
what i've heard he doesn't lie
well he's willing to be wrong and he
admits when he's wrong and he's able to
look at an issue without emotionally
jumping on it and and deciding what it
is immediately and the way he he
articulates the way he kind of
fact-finds this larger question that
whatever it's asked to him he goes
through these motions the way he
describes it is is a way that's
completely totally different than the
corporate media that has pr corporate
talking points that they literally
regurgitate and speak in unison as if
they were in a religion which they are
so i want to ask you know looking back
at this poll i'm i'm wondering why
i'm wondering why people feel that the
the country is in a state of decay well
it's it's a materials issue as well
we're on 150 year old materials when
we're working with steel it's super
heavy uh it's decaying it's things are
rusting um
and of course
here we go mike i want to ask you about
graphing no i don't know what i
mentioned
i think that we're literally
materials and people i don't understand
they don't understand that there could
be a we're gonna talk about drafting in
a little bit that's that's a ridiculous
segue in no i think it's part of the
decay that people i feel like i do as
well that's not what people are talking
about talking about culture
society the water we drink i can help i
can help with this i see what he's
trying to do and i see what you're
trying to do and what i might suggest is
at the root of this is what uh i think
they call the second law of
thermodynamics right we're living in a
state of entropy we're in a
disintegrating universe to your point
russ never sleeps sooner or later it's
coming for all the steel in the world
but it's also coming for our best
thoughts and our best ideas and the
things that we hold most dear that stuff
also has a shelf life and it has to be
nurtured it has to be watered it has to
be challenged um and and when we stop
doing that and accept being having our
belly scratched or having getting
letting ourselves be patted on the head
right that's a bad substitute for that
and that's not how you fight newton's
second law
well i i agree with you um but i wanted
to
i think we have to have a more direct
segue into this idea yeah there is there
is infrastructure decay in this country
we're not our roads are falling apart
our bridges are falling apart we're not
interested in these big projects i often
talk about how uh you know i'm in new
york and i'm crossing the williamsburg
bridge just looking at this monolith of
a structure that's existed since before
i was born as far as i know it's just
there and i get to use it nobody charges
me any money for it i can walk right
across it and those are those big
projects where effectively our society
said we're going to plant a tree whose
shade we know we will never sit beneath
and that means the next generations will
benefit from it i when i when i look at
this country as an estate of decay it's
because
it's it's for that it's for this reason
i see people self-interested trying to
extract as much as they can they feel
like the titanic is sinking and they're
trying to grab as much fine china and
silver where they can before they get on
that boat and get out of here leave us
all left you know drowning there's no
community anymore but but what i wanted
to say was i don't want to get too
negative with it because i'm wondering
if you know seeing joe rogan speak up
seeing his massive success is actually
an optimistic point that we actually are
seeing people
come together around certain ideas and
that decay is actually being reversed
yeah the people stealing the china don't
want a community and that's why i think
there's been such a concerted effort to
push a divide and conquer agenda that of
course puts people in different
political uh you know associations and
gangs and affiliations but
we have to also recognize if someone is
watching the corporate media non-stop
they are living in a totally different
world than someone who doesn't watch the
corporate media who does their own
homework who does does their own
research and actually gets their
information from different sources and
is able to actually discern information
for themselves rather than just hear you
know opinions and talking points that is
the establishment narrative so these two
different worlds are of course going to
be clashing with each other because
these are different realities that
people are living under that are
completely playing by different set of
rules that the other one other one is
not playing by i think you're i think
your metaphor is pretty great i mean if
if the economy that we're talking about
here or
our country is the titanic
right and if we're talking a post
iceberg titanic right the damage has
been rendered right we're on the clock
and things are slowly devolving if
that's if that's where we are right now
what's going on on the deck right some
people are taking to china some people
are angling for lifeboats some men are
doing about the most incredibly selfless
thing there is and stepping aside others
aren't others are putting on wigs and
dressing like women to get on the boats
meanwhile you got a captain who's got so
much nobility baked into him that he's
absolutely 100 going down with the ship
and then you have four dudes who
fascinate me more than anybody else the
guys in the string quartet who are
playing near my god to thee providing a
soundtrack unlike any other
for one of the greatest weirdest
disasters of all time and then you have
the cook
you know true story the last guy in the
water was the cook
and he was blind drunk and he helped a
lot of people into the uh the lat
into the lifeboats his name was joffin
charles joffin was the last guy in the
water and the only one to go into the
water who lived
and you can look him up and you'll love
his story point being there was a lot
going on on the deck of the titanic post
collision and there's a lot going on in
our country right now
that belies
that
percentage i'm getting the feeling that
some people are stealing the fuel out of
the boats and taking 20-person lifeboats
and getting on them by themself and
trying to have like these rich
and it's
not only are they taking the the little
trinkets they're taking our fuel they're
just by printing money they're ruining
our economy they're destroying any hope
we have of getting out of here my single
biggest regret in this whole thing in
terms of stuff i've said on the public
record
late in march i did one of the first
zoom shows right
after the lockdowns it was with the
captains of the deadliest catch and i
said to sink hanson in the middle of the
show you know for the first time and
these are crab fishermen by the way just
to stick with the nautical metaphor i
said for the first time in my life it
really truly seems like we're all in the
same boat right 15 days to flatten the
curve we're coming together we're going
to do it we're on the same boat oh
bullcrap you know what we're all in the
same storm but to your point our boats
are very different that guy's in a
dinghy that guy's in a yacht
right that guy's in a freighter that
guy's hanging onto a piece of driftwood
wondering if anybody's gonna pick him up
right so we have never been in the same
boat ever once but for the first time in
my life we really truly were in the same
storm
and dude that's amazing because
if you think of every other disaster
that you've lived through right i can
think of hurricanes up the gulf i can
think of the wildfires in in northern
california the dereko
that just knocked cedar rapids the
inland hurricane right we've got plagues
of ants we got all this other stuff but
they all affect very very specific parts
of our country
this was different this turned our whole
country into the titanic and whether
you're rearranging the life
the the deck chairs or playing near my
god to thee you know everybody's got
that it was the world too like 911
brought the us together kind of for a
few weeks but this is the whole world
let's let's let's talk about that decay
in a uh more material sense we got the
story from cnbc hiring falters in
december as payrolls rise only 199 000
though the unemployment rate fell to 3.9
percent i love this because the story
was published on a friday and for those
that aren't familiar friday is when you
announce stories you don't want anyone
to hear because they're not paying
attention because this is bad news but i
think when we're talking about any kind
of state of decay talking about what's
going on with the economy what's going
on with money printing and jobs
is a really big part of it and i know
especially you mike have tons of
experience with how the the jobs uh
market and labor works in this country
or doesn't or doesn't you know look it's
a
it's a funny thing the
the existence of
opportunity is an inconvenient truth for
a lot of people and my foundation we
started 13 years ago just trying to make
a more persuasive case for a few million
good jobs that existed that nobody
wanted right it was really just better
pr for welders steam fitters pipefitters
mechanics and so forth these 11 million
jobs that are currently open right now
the vast majority don't require a
four-year degree they require training
so
you're
you're probably old enough to remember
shop class was a thing once upon a time
shooting club was too that's right yeah
and homeek was too yes like real skills
and whether you were into that or not
you know the fact that they existed in
high schools gave a whole generation of
front row seat
to the optics of labor you could at
least look at a job and understood
understand at a glance that it exists
right that doesn't happen anymore we
took shop class out of high school and
that by the way was no no mean trick
right it used to be the vocational arts
so we took the art out of it called it
votec changed votech to shop then we
walked it around behind the barn and
shot it in the head and when we did that
the unintended consequences
we're still seeing them people wonder
why college is so expensive well hell we
just spent 50 years telling an entire
generation that they're completely
screwed without a four-year degree
so we free up a bottomless pile of money
to borrow in pursuit of that degree
meanwhile we affirmatively tell that
same generation that there's a whole
category of jobs that are beneath you
which surprise surprise just happen to
be the very jobs that are currently
going begging right now so we're lending
money we don't have to kids who can't
pay it back to training for jobs that
don't exist anymore and that's what that
headline's all about yeah people don't
seem to understand this when we talk
about
they say you know four million people
unemployed or what is the number four
and a half million people quit their
jobs last month
last month quit their jobs dude
and then you have 11 million job
openings and so
people who look at that at a you know a
cursory glance they don't understand
somebody who quits their job as an
insurance broker or middle manager at a
cracker factory
can't go become a petroleum engineer or
even a plumber so there may be a job
opening in certain trades or in certain
industries that don't correlate so we
have we have that problem i feel like
there's something fascinating in my
experience with a lot of uh people of my
generation millennials where they don't
understand
basic economics and i don't mean the
math i mean quite literally how to come
about resources and food
so you know i talked to the average
person from my hometown or that i've
that i you know that i know went to
college and their idea is if i want to
pay rent if i want to eat food i have to
get a job and in order to get a good job
i need a degree
whereas my mentality has always been i
suppose maybe because i raked leaves for
money or mowed lawns or or shoveled snow
you know growing up in chicago if i
needed money i'd have to go figure out
how i can do it so i'm a little kid and
so you know i asked my dad like what do
we do i wanna buy a toys like we'll get
make money i'm like how and he's like i
don't know figure it out so me and my
brother we we make kool-aid we go to the
we go to the park and we have a pitcher
and we'd sell glasses of kool-aid at the
baseball games or we would take a rake
and go ask people if they want to give
you money and knock on doors hey i'm
willing to do a job for you in exchange
for money i didn't need a degree i
didn't need it need to go and ask an
employer to employ me or fill out forms
it was literally i could ask another
person if there was an exchange to be
made i feel like our generation my
generation doesn't understand that well
they're being given a binary choice and
it's it's it's a false choice right it's
not one or the other
i remember in the debates rubio
said something he said um
he said what the country needs or fewer
philosophers and more welders and my
social blew up my foundation blew up
they were like hey this guy gets it he's
saying what you've been saying and i
said well
actually no i i'm not saying the problem
with society is too many philosophers
i'm saying it would be nice if we had
more philosophers who could run an even
bead and it'd be nice if we had more
welders who could talk intelligently
about nietzsche and descartes and it's
not like one or the other you can't say
oh look i'm going to be a leaf raker and
not be curious about the rest of the
world the thing i didn't have when i
went to community college in 1980 was
this thing right i didn't have
this little handheld device that ties me
into 98 of all the known information in
the world so if i just have a healthy
sense of curiosity and an internet
connection all right well guess what two
weeks ago i watched the lecture at mit
for free now that thing would have cost
thousands of dollars
but it's now
it's all available virtually for free to
anybody and so if you look at it through
that lens the idea that we're still
saying that the most expensive path is
the best path for the most people
that's a big lie and that's messing
stuff up there's a great there's a great
joke real quick uh someone posted on
reddit once if you could go back in time
and say one thing to shock the people of
the past what would you say
and someone commented i have in my
pocket a device which grants me access
to the summation of human knowledge i
use it to argue with strangers and look
at pictures of cats
that's a great quote i definitely don't
want to generalize too much but mike i
wanted to ask you this with college is
raking in so much money with with them
indebting so many children brainwashing
so many of them a lot of people are
arguing that colleges by and large cause
more harm than good what's your kind of
understanding of that especially when it
comes to the current situation in this
country which i would say is in part
responsible because of this
indoctrination system which some people
call an education system well there it
is just once i would like to be able to
to say what i mean and not have somebody
hear it and hit it back over the net in
terms of micah's anti-education i'm not
for the record i'm going to be as clear
as i can on on your podcast if if you're
if if you're not educated you're screwed
all right now having said that if you
think the only place you can get an
education is a university
you're screwed in a different way
that's
that's the big deception we've got it
baked into our heads that the only place
to get a worthwhile education
is the most expensive place in the world
that's why we have 1.7 trillion dollars
in student loans and obscenely that's
why we continue to hear about how those
loans ought to be forgiven
now this makes me crazy because in my
world
you know we've trained 1400 people
through my foundation to work in
usually the construction fields those
are the most popular welders in
particular
i know a lot of people who have done
really well who've gone through the
program and they're working now and
they've paid forty fifty thousand
dollars to buy a truck they need their
truck for their business big old diesel
truck you know these things they don't
grow on trees nobody's arguing to pay
off the loan on that truck
these are people who build our homes
these are people who keep the previously
aforementioned infrastructure
running
these are people who are fighting on the
front line against the second law of
thermodynamics and we're not gonna
nobody's proposing for a moment that we
help subsidize the tool that allows them
to do that job and yet
we will argue
from the rooftops about why it's good
and fair to pay off a college debt what
do you think about paying off uh in all
the interest on all the college loans
and then make the
companies eat the interest you got to
clarify paying off you just make it good
to zero the government is now the
government stealing money and using it
to pay for no no no no no
uh eliminating interest rates is just
interest rates
i'll give you specifics i have like 19
000 in student loan debt i've had for 21
years i paid the the minimum
monthly and i have more debt now at 21
000 than i did 21 years ago because i've
just been paying the minimum um
i've also had it on forbearance at times
when i couldn't afford it which to me is
like if i just got that interest to zero
i don't like 12 grand because all all
everything i've paid is just paying back
interest
this is i think similar to what you were
saying one of the issues i have is i
think the interest rates are are
predatory and a lot of young people are
being effectively ripped off so i think
there's a good middle ground and maybe
we can suspend interest rates but you
got to pay back what you spent something
like that but the issue is the way that
the narrative is framed why don't we
talk about any other debt why why is it
that we you know uh college degree
holders are some of the highest income
owners in the country so we're
effectively giving some of the
wealthiest free money or a forgiveness
well let's talk about other areas where
we can you know better the country or or
give people some relief you like ubi
do i like it yeah what would you do
about it i don't like it
and i and you know what and i i don't
have a great
reason other than
i don't believe the primary purpose of
work is transactional i don't believe
i don't believe you guys are sitting
around this table
for the paycheck i'm sure you enjoy it
but
it's a crooked road that we're all on
and if you're only here for the money my
guess is you're not going to have much
of an audience money's a tool would
interest
these cameras these microphones and then
the message is it's a happiness
invaluable it's a symptom
of
of
of a well-intended and well-executed
plan you know unless you're born into it
well look that's
nobody starts this race at the same line
it's not fair i get all that i get all
that and as far as the interest goes
look i'm i'm really of two minds right i
i really
pity
genuinely pity the pressure that we've
put on a whole generation of kids when
we lean into them to sign on the dotted
line and and when guidance counselors
and parents and everybody forms you know
along with your peers
the the pressure to borrow the money you
borrowed is is really obscene in my
world now does that mean i think the guy
or the woman who didn't take that loan
who went a different way do i think they
should be on the hook to pay off one
penny of that i don't but i do think
we can do a much much better job of
informing
the next generation and i'm not saying
your problem doesn't matter it's it it's
a bad deal i know i always get into when
i got into it i didn't understand
compound interest to the nth degree but
i knew that there was going to be
compound interest and financial literacy
is part of this too teaching that with
homec and some semblance of a skilled
trade and you know getting a kid through
high school understanding compound
interest understanding basic skills
under teaching work ethic for god sakes
you know there's a way to do it what do
you think is a great way for young
people to get into some sort of trade
right now or someone that maybe has lost
their job over the last two years what
what's like a few starting steps
well look if you're if you're willing to
roll up your sleeves if you if you're
willing to learn a skill that's in
demand i can personally tell you right
now i don't know of a single
construction operation and i know
hundreds of them who aren't hiring like
crazy we have been trying to expand and
build and we are we are jammed up
because there's a labor shortage there's
a materials shortage so should a young
person just call cold call construction
companies and let them know i'm ready
listen i you'll find i'm very very
careful with
cookie cutter advice but
if it were me yeah i'd do what he did
i'd knock on doors and say i want to
make money and here's what i'll do i'll
show up early i'll stay late i'll take a
bite of the crap sandwich when it comes
along what do you need what skill should
i dedicate the next six months of my
life to learning if it's welding so be
it who's your best welder by the way
i'll work for free
i'll start you tell i'm telling you
i've never seen this kind of opportunity
available and i will get i'll catch all
kinds of hell for saying this because to
your point earlier
when we talk about the existence of
opportunity there's a giant tendency of
a lot of people to go
those jobs suck
those jobs don't pay enough that's
because your capitalist greedy rapacious
bosses
uh are just simply not offering a fair
wage and that's what my buddies on the
left say my buddies on the right say
universally well you know the skills gap
you know you got 11 million open
positions because people are
fundamentally lazy and shiftless right
so and that's that's the problem it's a
binary lie
spoiled might be another another word
describe some of these individuals one
way uh one one thing i've often talked
about is
you know when i started doing the work
that i did i mean and luke as well
because we've i've you know been working
with luke for like a decade
we're sleeping on couches when i when i
would travel to other countries for work
related projects luke would be like hey
i'll come down let me crash on your
hotel couch or whatever because it saves
money but when i talk to a lot of these
you know when i started working for vice
so many people would say i want to do
what you do i want to travel around
and then i would tell them did you know
that i sleep on a couch right now when i
worked for vice and they were paying me
to fly around and report this news
and you know people assume it must be
this glamorous glorious job and i must
have i must be getting paid so much
money and i was sleeping on my buddy's
couch he'd wake me up at two in the
morning smoking pot being like what up
and like it was funny but it was
stressful at times and then i talked to
these other people that like i really
want to do that job and i'm like well
you know you're making money why don't
you go buy a plane ticket like oh my
rent is two grand and i want to have
this really nice apartment in
williamsburg and i just feel like i
don't even have that yeah so what's
what's your priority
comfort it was comfort not not the
mission so you brought that point that
no one here is is doing this for the
paycheck and i'll say this too i mean
just the paycheck just the paycheck
you know uh as long as i've
known luke luke got started with like a
handycam and he was confronting
politicians and powerful elites because
he was passionate about it i got started
with a little tiny gopro i just put on
my computer screen and i would talk
about things i saw in the news that i
had feelings about
from there you planted a seed and i just
wanted to keep doing it i wanted to keep
going i wanted to keep traveling i kind
of i wanted to keep talking about stuff
and somehow me and my living room with a
gopro turned into we got all these
cameras everywhere and these lights and
uh the the money was was secondary to
all of it it was
having a camera turned on talking about
what i think what i feel what i've
researched
proving the liars wrong fact checking
that's what i cared about now here we
are with the with a company we're
building more and i got to be honest um
the money is is is
not a factor in what our plans are i you
know i i don't put together say the cast
castle vlog where we have you know the
chickens and stuff because i was like
man we're gonna make so much money money
off this i was like i want to do
something cultural right we don't make
money off of it but we're having these
videos we're showing people behind the
scenes we're building culture we're
trying to inspire you know young people
that's everything we're doing we're
fortunate enough to be able to expand
also we just launched a charity that uh
basically we're building decentralized
software social networking software so
people can host their own content and
have subscriptions directly without any
kind of middleman that's great without
censorship with that company i could
take 50 million and hire like 50
developers and start building a factory
where we'll mass-produce raspberry pi's
or something like it pre-loaded with the
software turn it around keep it pro like
if they're willing to work and it's
complex to launch that system you needed
like a lot of prep and oversight well i
i also just want to say uh as well yeah
i also want to say it's very hard to
find a lot of labor thank you tim for
the couches i appreciate those very much
they're very important for me uh but i
think there's also an aspect here that
we should talk about and that is the
impact of of social media that glorifies
the super rich and the x and and
the excess that uh a lot of people
strive to of course have this kind of
cookie you said earlier it's different
for everybody i'd have to know who i was
talking to but i can tell you in general
a lot of people i know
who start welding
wind up with a plumbing certification
and many of them wind up with an
electric certification and many of them
wind up buying a couple of vans and
hiring three or four people and now they
have a mechanical contracting business
nobody talks about the incredible number
of small businesses that begin with the
mastery of a skill not with the
acquisition of a diploma
right i'm not saying that it doesn't
happen that way i'm just saying that we
got really really good at telling one
narrative when when college
got the pr campaign it needed back in
the late 70s we needed more people
going to big schools we needed more
doctors we needed more scientists that
that was real
and the pr push that came with it was
also real the problem is like all pr the
push for college
was
terrible because it came at the expense
of all other forms of education
regarding medicine uh and like
doctorship and stuff i thought that
maybe 12 years is insane and that if
someone can take the test and pass the
test in real time they can do the work
then they're qualified to be the doctor
uh i would love to see that evolution
does that is that something you ever
think about
not much because
because the medical field has it has a
set of challenges that are outside of my
lane but i will tell you just by way of
example i took a a young woman named
chloe hudson on fox and friends about a
month ago she came through our
foundation and she wanted to be a doctor
specifically she wanted to be a plastic
surgeon super super short version of the
story but she was ready to sign on the
dotted line and she was looking at
roughly four hundred thousand dollars in
medical debt over the course of whatever
it was six years
and she just freaked she just said i'm
not i'm not going to do it so she
applies for a work ethic scholarship
from my foundation we give her
six seven thousand dollars maybe maybe
you know i we didn't even pay for the
whole thing you know we just helped she
got what she needed though
today
four and a half years later she's making
130 grand a year at joe gibbs aerospace
she's one of their lead welders
this is a woman who's 28 years old
beautiful defies every pre-existing
concept you have of what a welder is
supposed to look like and she's killing
it she's killing it so
part of my job today is to talk about
all the stuff we're talking about now
but it's also to get chloe hudson on a
billboard to get her on the tv to
suggest to the producers of american
idol that we could have another show
called american icon and we could start
treating
people like chloe hudson
the way the producers of idol
treated
adam lambert and that guess what that's
what dirty jobs is for the last 20 years
i treat a sewer inspector the way access
hollywood treats brad pitt
that's my whole
deal whether it's on the foundational
side the missionary side of the
mercenary it would be awesome to have a
show where like they're on stage
building the piping system and then
they've rushed the water through at the
end and see like who could who did it
right whose pipes hold water yeah yeah
that's a great show well usually the
blue collar workers are a lot nicer and
a lot cooler than of course even all the
top list celebrities i mean after when
covet hit i was in the middle of new
york city i was like i was done with
this i moved out to new hampshire and i
met an amazing welder and diesel
mechanic named jay noon he also does man
camp up in new hampshire with the free
state project where he goes out and he
literally has all the children from the
community come in from the whole free
state project and says okay we're going
to be building stuff we're going to be
welding stuff we're going to be breaking
stuff down we're going to be building
stuff back up and it's a it's a way to
allow children to look at what they're
passionate about to explore it in real
life and and provide them with an avenue
in a pathway that isn't i'm going to be
a youtuber and let's be honest here when
ish hits the fan when the financial
system is already crumbling and
teetering on disaster those people are
going to be the latest superheroes in a
few years from now when we're dealing
with some serious financial
ramifications because those are the
people that are going to be able to do
something in our society compared to of
course the latte starbucks flip-flop
wearing yuppies who are going to be
wandering around like a horde of zombies
asking for handouts let me let me ask
you this mike um before i do real quick
just to address everybody we had all of
our internet backups just drop at the
exact same time which is particularly
strange i'll just leave it at that and
then we got our cto on it so everything
should be back sorry about the
interruption are we gonna get swatted
is this just a precursor to another stop
and frisk what's the end of that the
reason so i don't wanna you know we
gotta we we i wanna take uh digital
security as well as physical security uh
seriously but it this this may have been
an intentional takedown of some sort
we've got we've got uh three uh we
actually have four backup lines and they
all dropped at the same time which is
weird
yeah did you get the part where mike was
dancing i should have warned you guys oh
i have a lot of powerful enemies
yes was the the the micro jumping up on
the table that wasn't on the street you
didn't get me i'm like dancing
let me let me ask you a question in line
with uh what luke was just asking about
so
there's this this this trope i guess
this uh um i guess you call it trope
that liberals won't survive the
apocalypse that people in cities they
don't know how to survive they don't
have a hunt and there's a lot of people
who are more rural who believe they'll
probably fare better i think it's a it's
a bit of a fair assessment you know luke
was saying these these starbucks hippies
aren't going to do so well when when the
ish hits the fan and maybe these guys
who got farms or at least know how to
deal with chickens might do better but
you know you've traveled around you've
met people of all different backgrounds
all the different dirty jobs how do you
feel about that do you think that's just
a myth
well
if you had to choose a side
you know i mean it's walking dead time
okay like we're like you're you're gonna
have to hunker down in a place that is
primarily populated with
well well-educated thoughtful
writers and thinkers
or
hunters and gatherers and builders
what
what team do you go on when things get
sporty
look well that's why i'd say i got to
the countryside and find some more look
around i mean look you've answered your
own code
i i can see i can see where you're
coming from and from where i've been i i
know what i would choose
look
i'm
it's weird for me after 20 years of
dirty jobs because people see that show
and they figure that i'm that guy
i mean they figure that i can fix or
build or replicate
anything
you know and i don't know why because i
i never do it on the show i simply bear
witness and work as an apprentice
to people who can actually do it i
actually can't i mean that gene is
recessive my granddad had it but i
didn't you know dirty jobs was a love
letter to him that's another story my
point is
you know when we lost power for four
days in northern california
at the height of the lockdowns
i never felt
more helpless
there's nothing i could do except watch
my meat in the refrigerator slowly rot
and watch as the temperature of the
house slowly rose
and the thick arid smoke of the
wildfires just drifted down and a plague
of ants somehow on top of all of this is
in the house they everything was just
crapping the bed contemporaneously who
have the know-how
to fix them when they go down
whatever little hiccup you just had here
i had a similar one during that time and
we lost a prime time tv show you know we
were 50 minutes through and we lost the
whole thing had to start from scratch
but that's nothing when you think about
real
real pros and runways and affordable
electricity and indoor plumbing
you know
we're the people who need to be most
involved in this conversation do you run
afoul of people that
maybe promote or just stand by and watch
planned obsolescence run it's or like or
does that come up constantly are you
like we got to fix this thing because
it's broken because it was built to
break so that they can sell us another
one later that's so i mean yes is the
short answer the funnier answer is i
played uh i played tim allen's younger
brother on last man standing and the
first episode i did with him we were
standing backstage waiting for our
entrance
and we were talking about he this exact
topic came up
and tim like lost his mind telling me a
story about how a blender broke and how
he wanted to fix it with his grandson to
show him
show him how a thing can be salvaged and
repaired but of course it can't because
the whole thing's like two pieces of
extruded plastic and it wasn't designed
to be fixed it was designed to fail
and uh yeah we missed our cue because
tim allen was was screaming about
planned obsolescence you ever seen the
ted talk from the guy who tried to make
a toaster from scratch
yeah it's amazing isn't it yeah he
couldn't do it can't do it can't be done
so it can be done in the sense that
maybe if he if he tried making a steel
toaster but the plastic he could not do
right
it's amazing to me that
the technology we have
in the civilization is dependent upon
hyper-specific specialties
a computer is not just made by one
person doesn't make a computer it's made
by probably what several dozen
specialists in all these different areas
and more than dozens because if you
really want to get down to it you have
this factory that can make the chips
that runs the machines that talks about
the coolant fluid and all that stuff but
then you've got the people who are going
to source the chemicals for you people
who are going to source the metals for
it refine the metals it probably takes
how many i bet somebody in the audience
might actually know this how many
specialties does it take to make one
modern computer 300 400 more
probably more but the guy who mines the
copper yeah
isn't it funny though about
how when you talk about what it takes to
make this thing right or the computer
right whatever little piece of tech
you're most currently enamored of
um
all of the companies responsible want to
position themselves as innovators
because there's great sexiness that
comes with being an innovator i don't
care whether you're apple or google or
intel you go down the list and they all
talk about their incredible ability to
think ahead and innovate when in reality
their real talent the dirty jobs talent
is their ability to replicate
it's not enough to make one of these
things you guys all want one in fact if
you can't make a billion of them these
days you don't really have a business
so language matters and when you
see people
work so hard to associate themselves
so specifically with something like
innovation it's almost always at the
expense of imitation because imitation
gets a bad rap but these computers and
all the specialities that you're talking
about that's all based on henry ford's
vision
with art too if you can if you can
repeat yourself if you're a master of
repetition you can be a master artist
because you just keep doing it and then
it's going to come around when that
thing is is when it's needed and you got
it well now you're innovating that's the
scarcity model right if you're if you're
if you're making art for the masses or
technology for the masses then you
better have the duplication gene down
but if you're looking for what nfts if
you're looking for
uh originals you know there's only
there's only one
whistler's mother there's only one mona
lisa but you could you could say that uh
an original is a bunch of replications
mixed pushed together into one new
uber rep replication that people
consider original like when i write
music i take notes from songs that i
heard in the past and create a new song
we're all standing on the shoulders of
giants sure there's a there's a great
anime it's called dr stone have you ever
you ever hear of it no i can't imagine
you would have but uh i've actually not
watched a whole lot of it but it's uh
the premise is i'm gonna get this wrong
for fans of dr stone to get mad at me uh
this genius kid and his friend i guess
everybody turns to stone in the world
for some reason
and then thousands of years later for
some reason this ultra genius and his
you know friend or whatever or he he
de-stones them or whatever basically the
premise is he's this really smart kid in
a prehistoric time or at underdeveloped
time and he's developing technology so
i've only seen a couple episodes but
he's like i'm gonna make a cell phone
and the episode is actually him
directing people to find the medals and
explaining how vacuum tubes work and i'm
like it's like magic school bus but for
anime fans yeah i thought it was
actually really fascinating to to have
this um
action-oriented show for kids explain
how a vacuum tube works and he as he's
putting it together and making the glass
so it's fascinating he's like okay to
make the tube we need to make glass
here's what we need to find to make the
glass here's what we need to make to to
blow the glass here's the metal we need
and then he tries to find the proper
filaments but you can't find the right
you know that can withstand the right
temperatures i think it was brilliant
because when you when watching that i
think it would give a lot of people
especially millennials you know
i shouldn't pick on millennials
everybody needs to understand this that
when it goes into the the basics of
what's in your tv you have no idea
the precision
and the and the hard work and the trial
and error that went into inventing all
of these things and how we're very lucky
that we've written things down and
passed them on right you made my own
point better than i did that's what i
was trying to say when you're when
you're sitting there in the dark and you
can't get your own power back on you
realize just how decoupled you've come
from the chain of knowledge that allows
you to be your own solution right i
remember
if you ever watch star trek
absolutely
don't get me started on star trek what's
the what's the prime directive the prime
directive in star trek well you can't
interfere with another culture unless
they've reached capabilities correct all
right good for you and that's only and
it's only because once they reach warp
they're inevitably going to encounter
other civilizations they have to um
so i'm hiking through
um peru
15 20 years ago
cusco to machu picchu i'm with some
buddies and we hired some sherpas to
help us because we had a lot of gear and
you know we didn't want to carry it all
and uh these guys were unbelievable
their giant lungs giant heart they would
start walking around 11 in the afternoon
we'd start walking around sorry 11 in
the morning we'd start walking around
six they'd pass us by four running in
bare feet right con per miso compare
i love these guys and i had a
i had a walkman i had a sony walkman at
the time and i was listening to
soundgarden super unknown had just come
out
and i am just walking through the clouds
listening to this and it's so great and
on the last day i thought you know what
these guys were so awesome
i i put the headphones on one of the
guys who had never been below 12 000
feet in his whole life by the way never
heard an electric guitar
and i put on spoon man
okay
so
watching his face
listening to chris cornell
sing
and through those headphones it was just
like i knew in a second this was this
was my gift you violated the front dude
and i and i've been tortured ever since
because hey like somewhere in in the
andes is probably a
a stone built thing that looks like a
walkman
but but but then like what happened when
the batteries
went out and now the the magic sounds
are gone forever what
what's that going to do
there's this fascinating quote i heard
that you could give christopher columbus
unlimited resources
and he would never build you a nuclear
submarine
because the the the understanding of of
nuclear energy just it's beyond anything
they could put together it's like a kid
it's like adults aren't capable of doing
the thought processes then that's part
of why we have young minds to do that
and why are they still in office
politically there's something that i
always that that that i um
perhaps mistakenly believe is
fascinating probably a lot of people
just think i'm an idiot but i i love
asking people this question fine line
man fine line between fascination and
idiocy so i i but but i realized
something when i would ask people this
question
how do coal power plants work how do
they create electricity or do you know
i'd imagine right
uh so uh what what do they do how does
how do we turn coal into electricity
well you got a turbine primarily and uh
i mean first you got to go into the
earth you got to get it out we live not
far we're sitting not far from where
that happens and then you got bituminous
and you got anthracite and the
approaches are slightly different but in
the end the coal's got to wind up inside
a turbine you're getting way more
specific than i normally get
well i
go ahead with your explanation because i
have a slightly different way we just
boil water
oh okay right great yeah yeah yeah
you're like here's the chemical
breakdown we we we burn stuff we boil
water yeah steam pressure spins a
turbine that's it rotating uh rotating
magnets generates an electrical current
and vice versa uh how do we how does
nuclear energy how do we take nuclear or
radioactive uranium and turn it into
electricity
um we we boil it even hotter we boil
water
steam pressure spends a turbine and then
there's the uh the solar fields
the how do we you know
a lot of people think it's all
photovoltaic but actually many of them
just direct uh uh someone corrected me
someone did correct me on this once we
direct all these mirrors towards a vat
of salt water i believe it's solid
molten salt molten salt it's even more
because it holds the heat for longer and
then creates steam pressure spins a
turbine boiling water boiling water so
you're talking about uh what do you do
when your power is out and you can't you
know get that going well the problem is
getting a turbine yeah there's your
problem so it's like even even
understanding something as basic as
steam pressure can spin something you
know it's not particularly complicated
how do you build a turbine you can need
some copper you have to get a lot of
copper and coil it do it properly
it's crazy i just finished the show
called uh six degrees
which sounds a little bit like dr stone
it's kind of a magic school bus sort of
thing that surprising connections that
take you down this serendipitous line of
of uh
of invention but um
part of the thing that i really wanted
to do with that show was ex like
there were a few things that really just
chat my ass and and one is electric cars
and just the idea that we're so in love
with them because electricity is so much
better than
fossil fuels
and
you know if you
if you just follow the electricity back
from the plug yeah you know you're gonna
get to a spinning turbine and the odds
are
very very very high that turbine is
being powered by gas
or oil
and you just can't you you you can't
separate the two
uh for all the virtue in the world you
just can't do it we got storage issues
with power if we want to use wind what
happens when you know wind is low solar
doesn't work at night
uh geothermal is fantastic but you got
to be in the right positioning you know
the right place for it and so for the
time being we are heavily dependent on
fossil fuels which means burning them
and creating a lot of carbon lightning
is going to change when we can start
harnessing lightning
we're going to boil a lot of water nail
a battery and you know why we can't
though
we we can't pronounce everything we can
well it's just we can't predict voltage
amperage the bolts are seemingly random
to us yeah you have to stick something
way up in the sky like a tether maybe
the space elevator to use as like a
lightning rod and then the elevator
itself the tether could be the super
conductor the issue is we can't we can't
properly measure the output
so while it seems to a lot of people
like oh you should be able to no we
can't because when all of our electro
systems have to be they're specific can
can the the the can we handle the load
typically you're right the load is way
beyond anything we normally deal with
but we also just don't know what it is
yeah it's lightning man it's like
yeah well i think the big point is the
fundamentals boiling water is
fundamental building a turbine is more
sophisticated the jobs that are going
wanting right now are fundamental
they're fundamental jobs and
the fact that most of us have become
disconnected from those jobs and the
people who do them
that
that's how we land the plane on the
skills gap it's not just a skill gap
it's a will gap you know it's a lack of
will on the part of many many many
millions of people who rely on the
people with the skill we're just not
properly gobbs a little personal story
here my sink just broke a couple days
ago and now it's been leaking underneath
i was like well gotta gotta hire a guy
to fix it i think i want to fix it dude
everybody's got that story i want to get
down there and fix it i'll tell you this
man when when it hits the fan
very few people are going to be crying
for uh academics or buzzfeed reporters
but they're going to be begging for a
plumber they're going to say please make
my poop go away what do i do with it
that's that's my whole life now that i i
ask that question every day how long do
you want to wait
for the re refrigerator repairman for
the plumber and speaking of you said you
were in the sewer what was life like in
the sewers i've never been in one before
that's pretty great man
tell me more i've been i've been in one
before
well i mean if you want to get back to
the fundamentals i mean that's how dirty
jobs started with a sewer inspector in
san francisco in 2002
and um
it's another it's
it's another world it's it's the classic
out of sight out of mind
thing but you know this is a 120 year
old system
millions of bricks down there many many
many millions of roaches the size of
your thumb countless rats you're
knee-deep truly in a river of crap
and it's
good how much did they get paid
oh that sewer inspector did about well
it was a city job so he said i think it
was 82 500. oh
wow you know private we should we gotta
i i i i volunteer to pay more taxes to
make sure those people get more money
man look he loved his job i mean 82 000
a year
he says how many years ago was this
this was close to 20. yeah this is
that's a lot more compared to what it's
worth now
he has no supervision
he has nobody monitoring him his job
was he he
he
hammered out the bricks that we're
starting to rot and replace them so all
he did he'd go down there he'd mix his
mortar he'd hammer out the bricks that
had succumbed to the second law of
thermodynamics and he hammered in a new
one wearing like a full suit though
right no no no tyvek you know you know
like a rubber now he had a heavy duty
rubber suit but this that what people
don't understand about sewage is that
it's got chemicals and stuff it could be
it's corrosive right everything people
think their toilet is like different
from their sink like different drains go
to different pipes that go to no it all
goes to the same basic place so when it
rains
it being in a sewer during a rainstorm
is a whole different deal but also being
in a sewer it's it's not just a river of
urine and crap coming at you it's all
the stuff that goes down the toilet it's
like a medicine cabinet it's it's
it's it's uh it's q-tips it's kotex is
it just black though no it's it's it's
more brown really some of it is it's not
as thick as you think some of it
sometimes it gets pretty thick it
depends how the
fixed film reactors and the lift pumps
are we should do a field trip yeah and
uh investigate further i mean we're
doing the show live right
live from the sewers of west virginia or
wherever we are let's let's go to super
chats because we got a lot of questions
and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel go to
timcast.com become a member
and we're going to have a members only
segment up around 11 or so p.m where
we're gonna it's it's we call it the
uncensored segment and uh make sure to
make sure to help support our work over
at teamcast.com let's read some of what
we got here
gino fast says mike would you ever climb
the mackinaw bridge again no
what was that about
the mackinac bridge is uh i think it's
the longest suspension bridge in the
country and it connects the upper and
lower peninsulas of michigan right so
it's a it's a giant green
suspension bridge
and uh they've been painting it
constantly ever since its construction
it never stops once you finish painting
you just start painting it again i went
there one day to paint the bridge and to
go down into some of the uh
oh the towers and to see what the inside
looked like and how that maintenance was
done
and the reason he's asking that question
is because at the end of the day i did
something
that i do from time to time on the show
usually just as kind of a gag but i
asked permission to do something i i
knew they would say no to right as a
joke on camera i said to the supervisor
hey you know what would be fun before we
go
and we got a great segment so no
pressure but it'd really be fun if if i
could walk across that girder off the
deck and then go over that stanchion and
then walk up the uh the cable and change
a few light bulbs you know five six
hundred feet above the water
and um oh my and this guy looks at me
and says
okay
and literally my sphincter slammed shut
i'm like oh god so so 10 minutes later
i'm walking across the girder
and going up the cable and we got a
helicopter with a west cam rig on it and
so and so we got the best sh that
segment actually won an emmy wow um but
the the business of walking up that
cable and changing those uh light bulbs
like when you look down when you're 600
feet up and you look down at the water
you know you've got big freighters
coming and going underneath you they
look like the ships in battleship these
tiny little things you know and it's
just uh it was just one of those shows
that took place way up in the air and
people like 600 feet above the the
bridge and then below the bridge it goes
more no it's 600 feet to the water it's
probably two
300 feet above the deck
all right we got some uh we got some big
fans invisible dud says mike rowe is the
equivalent of a modern founding father
who else would be on that list
great question wow i don't know
but your sweat pledge you were
mentioning before the show was just yeah
yeah well look sometimes you know if
you're trying to figure out the degree
to which somebody likes a thing you have
to look at the degree to which other
people hate it
right and and the sweat pledge
breaks a lot of uh eggs every year it's
a simple 12 step or 12 tenant pledge
that everybody has to sign who applies
for a for a work ethic scholarship and
there's nothing founding father-ish
about it although
the uh the the ideas are are timeless
you know it's a it's a shameless love
letter to work ethic delayed
gratification a positive attitude and a
measure of personal responsibility and i
know all those things have become dog
whistles and problematic terms for a lot
of
for a lot of people but i
i'm earnest about that and i and i mean
it those that combination of qualities
is still
i think your best hope of success i
agree i think it's math i think anybody
who wants to insult those ideas they can
say whatever they want because in 20
years you'll be successful and they'll
be begging for change i thought you said
it's meth
which is so different than math mbma
i got one here from common sense fishing
he says
i'm an hvac c20 contractor started my
business january 1st 2020 dirty hands
equals clean money yes some hvac
salesmen make 200 to 400k got into the
trades after my son passed away in o6
they can never take a skilled trade away
that dude needs to be on a billboard yes
and i mean that that look this is my
my life's work i'm just a i'm just an
entertainer who had who hit a show but
the legacy of dirty jobs
it was an honest show and i i guarantee
this guy would agree but we we profiled
a dozen hvac guys on that show
they
all are crushing it but never mind the
money they love what they do they're
superheroes without capes they show up
to people's homes in phoenix when it's
110 outside and they fix the air
conditioning those people weep they show
up to similar homes in boston in
february
where it's 20 degrees inside and they
and they fix the heat you know that guy
has a measure of job satisfaction
that most people are simply not
not going to experience and uh good on
him i think this next comment
exemplifies why
you've got so many fans especially
joshua leblanc says micro and dirty jobs
inspired me to find a great job in the
trades decided college wasn't for me and
now i make more than i would have if i
stayed
i think yes look
what
dude it's it's a it's a freaking
honor and a privilege to work on a cable
tv show and have a guy like you read a
tweet like that
sitting here surrounded by guitars
swords rocks
[Laughter]
yes
i think you know uh for me especially
i was told when i was a teenager you
have to go to college and i i was
thinking about it and i was like okay
you know that's what i'm told to do and
then i started i mentioned this before
the show i read an uh an article from an
economist who said it was the stupidest
investment you could make forty thousand
dollars now in four years you owe 40
grand plus interest and you have no job
prospects doesn't seem to make sense for
an investor and so i decided against it
after occupy wall street i still had
people saying are you going to go to
school now and the craziest thing to me
is i was like they're asking me to speak
at their schools about the streaming
stuff that i'm doing there's something
strange i think about this generation
and even the boomers telling them you
know millennials go to college where
they they think college is a requirement
to success i thought yeah you know i'll
try making sure this point quick but you
know what i think happened is
i was told this by you know my family
and the previous generation my elders
that
when they didn't go to college they
ended up working as managers at grocery
stores or department stores and they
made okay money but their friends and
family members who went to college ended
up making six figures and they're rich
that's why you have to go to college to
get a good job
but back then
the boomers the you know the kids coming
out of world war ii
you could have a high school diploma and
raise a family on that so you didn't
there was no one telling you had to go
to college which means the people in the
boomer generation who went to college
chose to because they were chasing a
passion
yeah so in my opinion the reason they
think their success in college was
because passionate people went to
college not because college made people
successful
no look at tracks i mean when my
grandfather to whom dirty jobs was
dedicated by the way went to work
he was 14. he only went to the seventh
grade he wanted something better
for his kids than he had he wanted them
to have
more choices better opportunity it's not
because he didn't love what he did
he just wanted more for them and his
kids wanted more for for me
and
look this is it's part of the fault in
our
stars because while it's normal to want
something better
for our kids than we had
to your point it's math exponentially it
doesn't play out
at what point is better pretty good i
mean how are my kids gonna have it
better than me
good grief right so
that thing there is a thing in all
well-intended parents that that want to
push their kids
into something better we just don't know
what better is it's not more money
that's for sure well you know you know
my dad's situational my dad would say to
me when i was little what do you want to
be when you grow up and no matter what
i'd say it's a wrong answer the right
answer is
happy
so i think that's the mentality he had
is you know to have a life better than
me i just want to make sure you are
happy with your life
look okay and and so
going back to platitudes bromides and so
forth and tropes
uh
here's one that that chaps my ass like
none of the other ones
it's
follow your passion
i hear that
i hear well-intended people
telling kids that every day
so
now when i when i rant on this people
push back and say well what what good is
life without passion and i say i'm not
saying life without passion is the point
the better platitude is never follow
your passion but always bring it with
you and that's the dirty jobs lesson i
never met anybody on dirty jobs who was
unhappy in their work but nor did i meet
anybody who set out to do
the very thing
they were doing when i met them
which means
they didn't sit down at 17 identify the
thing they wanted to be and then embark
on some great grand quest to borrow
whatever it took in order to maybe get
the magical piece of paper that would
give them a shot at possibly attaining
the thing that would give them
permission to feel that which your
father described as happiness right
that's that's we're still telling kids
that's how to do it the dirty jobs
corollary was no
follow opportunity
go
look at where everybody else is going go
the other direction when you get there
figure out how to be good at whatever it
is then
then
figure out a way to love it yeah all
right the cat says mike what was your
favorite episode or job when you were
doing dirty jobs well there was a time
when we ate the cat
what kind of cat you actually ate a cat
no i was riffing on the i think the
handle of this person is eat the cat eek
oh eek
see that's again that's totally
different meth to math eek to eat very
similar uh did eek use the word favorite
is is that the question
what's my favorite your favorite episode
or job when you were doing dirty jobs
well eek the cat here's the thing man um
dirty jobs
really wasn't about the dirt or the job
it was about the people it was
the dirty little secret of that show was
that it's a talk show in a sewer or on
top of a bridge or in an air duct
somewhere and so
you know when i look back at all of it
now yeah sure there's feces from every
species and misadventures and animal
husbandry but it's the people mostly
that i stay in touch with although there
was that time we masturbated the turkey
yeah that was an epic story by the way
well maybe maybe we'll we'll have you
tell that story in the members only it's
probably best there
because then you can tell like over like
it was over a beer yeah because i don't
want to i don't want to pull any punches
when it comes to the right low wake up
let me let me read you this one i i saw
this one early in the show and i have to
read it wimplow says mike rowe i would
listen to you read from the yellow pages
all right who's in charge of the screen
up there that's me all right well i mean
technically we can both control it so
type micro reads phone book
of oh i read the phone but no it's it's
on youtube somewhere it's amazing people
told me people for years people were
like i'd listen to you read the phone
book so one day i did i just read the
phone book
there it is i read the freaking phone
book
and people still play it today for their
kids for whatever reason how many views
does it have six
no i don't know it's got i mean it's up
there in a lot of different pieces it's
it's i don't know probably a thousands
genius at least a thousand i'm sure do
you ever do any book reading well this
this one there's a bunch of different
versions yeah
70 000 views on this 70 000 views on
this one there was a bunch of there's a
bunch of them no it's it's it's it's
still up there that's funny that's great
well i'm in the booth every day reading
something and so usually i get done
whatever i get paid to do and then um
i do something random and weird and one
day it just seemed like
it was just time to read the phone book
guys you know that's great it's time all
right falcon laser says mike i loved
your narration of how the universe works
what do you think the hubble deep field
will look like when taken by the james
webb telescope man
okay so the deep field
is
my favorite photograph ever taken for
those of you who don't know what we're
talking about it was basically aft after
they fixed the the botched lens on the
hubble and got it out there where it's
supposed to be
they pointed it
at this very controversial moment
in the hubble history but because
there's a long line of people who wanted
to point the hubble at very specific
things to get all kinds of research done
and this guy i forget his name he wanted
to point it at nothing hubble time was
very rare so he he pointed it at the
blackest
hunk of nothing there was
and started taking pictures and what
came back basically was what the
universe
looked like
about
400 000 years after the big bang
which in real time or practical time is
like a second right and what we see in
the hubble deep field
is it at a glance it just looks like a
big giant sky full of stars that you
would see out in the desert except the
car the the stars are colorful and the
reason they're colorful is because
they're actually galaxies whoa and the
the sky is is full of billions of
galaxies and so it's a it's the closest
thing we have to what
the beginning of the universe look like
what the web is going to do with that
photo i
my guess is this is i i think we're
going to see more galaxies and more
color wow it's the uh
name is bob williams that decided to
point it at nothing bob williams guy
yeah 1995. now did you just google that
or did you know that yeah i just looked
it up on duckduckgo because if you knew
that you know that that was not that
great i'm so happy you didn't say the g
word you ready for the for a spicy one
brilliant
buddy says what's worse micro neutering
sheep with his teeth or cnn eating human
brains
i mean in my opinion eating human brains
is much much worse than a dirty job
situation well it depends what you're
doing for right like why was the cnn guy
eating live human brains right
why were you doing what you were doing
as described by that commenter right
i don't think it was alive brains i
think no one was harmed in the eating of
the brains
of those brains well look i mean but
weirdly the uh
the story he's talking about was uh was
it was called lamb docking and part of
it was castration of sheep uh the
old-fashioned way we were up in craig
colorado and for years that's what the
ranchers did they
you know they literally bit the
testicles off the
the creature and they did it for a lot
of reason this is another story if you
want i'll walk you through it in the in
the members
because i mean it involves you know
words like you know vas defronts scrotum
knife
i have to say that um reza aslan of cnn
has a job
net job while he was at cnn involved
eating brains and it sounds dirty does
this sound pretty dirty not a dirty job
i would recommend though yeah
that's another level then dirty in my
opinion well have you eaten has anybody
eaten brains i never have no
you know they're in the partner program
they're still
uplifted in the algorithm they ate human
brains on national television and that's
how cnn gets ratings yep yeah exactly
yeah man
i think the dude lost it after that man
all right anomaly oh hey i saw anomaly
and bryson gray super chatted nominee
says thank you tim for the shout out on
my song with bryson gray you and your
beanie are going to hit the billboard
charts with us let's go king
there's a there's a line anomaly wraps i
ain't going nowhere like tim fool's
beanie
oh yeah yeah so i got sent that and i
was like this is officially the greatest
song of of any generation and i had to
tweet it out so shout out guys that was
great it's pretty cool to to to hear
your name in a song you know it's a good
song actually well that's even better
well yeah i mean
you know they they shouted me out so i
shot him out back you know like yeah
it's only polite i thought it was a good
song too it's good it's it's called
controlled i believe and it's about
it's about manipulation
it's a good song you guys check it out
bryson gray anomaly controlled
done all right let's see we got
let's grab some super chats
steeler country says just earned my anp
license my options are endless now trade
skills are needed now more than ever if
you care for your children's future
advocate for more trade activities in
your community keep it up mike rowe god
bless
thank you i will i got to say you know i
a lot of the super chats are people
pointing out how you've rescued them by
you know informing them and inspiring
them on trade jobs
look there's so many people saying go to
college go to college go to college
there's there are memes where it's like
you know guy he's got like a big beard
and he's making coffee for 12 bucks an
hour complaining about his college debt
and then there's a guy with a hard hat
working on power lines making 100k a
year
no debt look i i i had a front row seat
to it i mean that's
like i said dirty job started as a tv
show and a tribute to my pop
and then
it just got out of control and then the
viewers stepped up and started
suggesting all the ideas
and then you know after you do 50 60 80
of them you you can't help but look
around and ask yourself what what does
this group of people know that i don't
you know why are they having such a good
time yeah and what can we maybe learn
collectively from it and that's you know
well it appears flattery has no limits
shawn byrne says this man was the dad i
never had i got a sense of hard work
from your shows
is that sean with an h or e
with an h a w that's weird because i
have a son named sean and i haven't seen
him in a long time oh there you go sean
is it you man
is it you what's up homie you're
familiar with jordan peterson i am
jordan peterson has a a similar and sort
of different message though i think what
really resonated with a lot of young men
was the hard work personal
responsibility
and i think you you you both have a
similar you know a target in a different
way
dirty jobs
not only does it give respect to the
people who make the system work and
highlight jobs that most people take for
granted but it also inspires people to
work hard and get active and find you
know find a way through it without going
to college or i hope so you know the the
big difference you know jordan has an
enormous brain and he came out of
academia and so he really he came in hot
right with his world view and
and there was nothing for him to hide
behind
but for his opinions i had a show you
know i was i'm i'm i'm crawling through
rivers of crap i'm making dick jokes i'm
just having a time right you know and
that got people's attention and then i
was able
only then was i able to start asking
questions like you know maybe
maybe these careers sure they're dirty
but let's look a little closer and by
then i'd i had permission you know i i
had permission to weigh in right so
jordan never had permission he just did
it and that that took a whole different
level of uh
moxie well uh says how did dirty jobs
show shape your perspective
well it didn't shape it
it
i grew up
keenly aware of where my food came from
where my energy came from
how things got built i i worked on a you
know i grew up on a small farm and i had
i was surrounded by by
that world
and when i got into entertainment i left
all that
behind not intentionally but you know
way leads on to whey and after 20 years
of freelancing in entertainment and
singing in the opera and selling crap in
the middle of the night on qvc and
having 150 different jobs
um i had become
really disconnected from a lot of those
things that dirty jobs celebrates and so
when my mom called me to tell me my
grandfather wouldn't be around forever
and that maybe he'd like to see
something on tv that looked like work
before he died
that drove me into the sewer and that
footage turned into dirty jobs and you
know to answer his question what dirty
jobs did
was
become my actual
education i went to a community college
for two years and then later i went to a
university but my education didn't start
until i was 42
in the sewers of san francisco
followed by dirty parts unknown what did
your grandfather think of the show he
saw one episode he looked at it and he
laughed and he had any and he gave me
the slow clap all right yeah nice all
right jameis 714 says does mike think
unions are a good place to start
well that would require a broad-based
platitudinous
cookie-cutter answer
so here's the thing with unions
i have
absolute great respect for their
existence i belong to one
and i have for a long time
but um i'm i'm very hesitant to say a
way is the right way my foundation has
hooked a lot of people up with a lot of
unions and a lot of different vocations
and many of them are happy
uh we've also
given away a lot of money over the years
in in right to work states and helped a
lot of people who are very satisfied
today outside of the union i honestly
don't think
i don't think there's
a simple answer it depends on the
industry it depends on the local it
depends on the shop steward
you know look
not to turn this whole thing into a
polemic but when
i
tried to get dirty jobs on the air i
called the union and they said don't do
it discovery's not a signatory and you
would be running
running afoul of what's called global
rule one
and uh that could result in fines and
possible right same thing happened uh
years before that at qvc my first job in
tv they were like they're not a
signatory you can't do it
i heard that a lot from my union and i
had to decide you know it wasn't quite
like the scab question because there
were no strikes going on
but the decision to work outside of the
screen actors guild was very difficult
for me to make
but had i not made it
we wouldn't be talking today and you
know
i'd be having a very different
conversation with somebody else that's
crazy sometimes the conventional methods
the institutions aren't the way to go
and sometimes they have your own way you
really do man you've just gotta if if if
people take
if people forget everything i've said
but just remember the one thing it's be
be wary of of all earnestness and look
askance at cookie cutter advice so we
got silently in atlanta he says wow mike
rowe that was the first super chat
asking me to bring him on you really
started an opera singer i did
yeah uh 1984
um it was a uh it was a very strange
time because that union i just mentioned
i was desperate to get into i was
desperate to be a member of the screen
actors guild because i couldn't find an
agent who would represent a non-union
guy
but i couldn't get in the union unless i
had a union job so
that's the catch the loophole was
joining something called agma which was
the american guild of musical artist and
then buying your card in the sister
union
the uh the challenge of course was to
get into the opera in order to be a
member of agma
so yeah i learned the shortest aria i
could find it was a
from a puccini uh
opera called labo m it's called the coat
aria i walked around with the uh
with the with the walkman listening to
samuel raymie sing
vekias
shenders
[Music]
that's great because by singing that we
own the rights to that recording and it
goes sample it and do it sample the hell
out of i love it
we make music we got a studio here
i love it look i just recorded a song
with john rich before um christmas
called santa's got a dirty job and we
raised i mean like a lot of money for
our foundation so yeah
so music has always been a thing in my
life the opera was a very very weird
turn
but i got in it my plan worked what
happened that i didn't anticipate was i
stayed for eight years
in the opera yeah wow yeah i freaking
loved it wow marcel lacrima says late to
the start of the cast please mask ask mr
mike when he is running for president
friday four-ish oh perfect
hey they might take that seriously and
say that was a declaration you know it's
it's actually super flattering but i
think more than anything it just it
to the very early things we were taught
and we weren't having a big political
conversation but we were talking about
authenticity and and and the reasons
that so many journalists and politicians
and even scientists
um have have lost their have lost their
credibility it's it's weird people
started asking me to get into politics
shortly after i crawled through the
sewer
and i think part of the reason was
you see a guy covered with somebody
else's crap and you know he's probably
not going to try and sell you something
or or i mean and really why would he lie
to you you know i mean you literally i
had condoms stuck
to my rubber hip boots
i mean
that guy
whatever else you say about him he's not
going to lie to you
well they call washington dc a swamp so
i could see the comparison as well
this is under the swamp he's a part of
the swamp he has to be elected we had we
had a few comments some said have you
ever been hired to clean the swamp or
you should work you should do a show in
politics because that's the dirtiest job
there is and things like that my my
favorite question that i saw in the
comment section and i kind of wanted to
ask you is the question if cleaning the
gulags is going to be on a future
episode of dirty jobs
cleaning the gulag as in like gulaga
archipelago no no like the political
gulags that are all going to be interned
into uh you know oh god that's so
depressing
i mean
see i'm thinking of alexander
solzhenitsyn yes who wrote gulag
archipelago and of course cancer ward
which ought to be required reading today
because i mean
look you're
it's a cautionary tale and it's a big
hunk of history and uh who was it santa
anna right we don't learn from the past
we repeat it that would be a great
comedy sketch actually
political prisoners the gulag edition
yeah all right i'll run it up the
flagpole thanks for that ladies and
gentlemen i am i am very eager and
excited to get to this member segment so
i'm going to say go to timcast.com
subscribe if on the top right you can
sign up and around 11 or so pm we will
have that exclusive members only podcast
at timcast.com with micro telling a
story about how he once
uh tube and a turkey among other stories
it's gonna be weird guys i'm not gonna i
don't wanna oversell it but you might
wanna wake up grandma she's gonna wanna
hear this i love it and uh
smash the like button subscribe to the
channel you can follow the show tim
castaire everywhere follow us on
instagram we post clips you can follow
me at timcast do you want to shout
anything out your foundation anything
like that dirty jobs is back sunday's at
eight microworks is going to give away
another million bucks in a month or two
and work ethic scholarships you can
apply at microworks.org other than that
you know there's books and stuff and
wildebeest traveling the vast reaches of
the baron serengeti
and so forth mike you are great thank
you for everything you're doing thank
you for for coming on the show i thought
it was great and you know a lot of
people need to hear
instead of those platitudes and mass
generalizations some kind of real honest
advice and and not just talking points
so thanks so much for having that um i
also have my own media organization on
youtube.com forward slash we are change
i j i just did a very interesting video
on the novak yokovich situation and i
did a pretty crazy video on
lukeuncensored.com hope to see some of
you guys there thanks for having me and
uh today was really a great episode that
was fantastic blue mike thanks dude
you're welcome thank you uh ian
crossland check me at ian crossland.net
and i will see you guys next time and i
want to leave you guys with this quote
from jordan peterson because we
mentioned him earlier jordan peterson
said to notice that opportunity lurks
where responsibility has been abdicated
i think that's a perfect summary of what
micro stands for and i wanted to say too
that the whole sweat pledge is 100
something that i intend to teach my kids
when i eventually have them
you guys yeah it's like the perfect
encapsulation of everything i want them
to understand about work um you guys may
follow me on twitter at sarah patchlids
we will see you all over at timcast.com
so check it out we'll see you then
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you